I have a question for you yeah 2024
Trump versus DeSantis number one what do
you want to happen number two what do
you think will happen
it's a great conversation we've had it
many times I don't think it's pretty I
think it's going to be ugly I think it's
uh this is a part where I'm going to
kind of agree with you on give you
something that you're going to be able
to talk about I think there could be a
civil war on the Republican side I don't
think it will be pretty and I think if a
DeSantis or a trump is wise specifically
more on The Descent side you have to do
negotiations up front before 2024 comes
around meaning
my Camp is sitting down with Trump's cam
right now having conversations
to see if we can do anything here
because if Trump comes out doing what
Trump's going to do it's going to be you
know how Bernie came out calling out
Biden calling out Warren calling out all
that stuff but guess what Bernie did at
the end of the day
he broke them back and he fell in love
there's no way so this is going to
happen who's the favorite right now
between Trump and desantises so you
agree with that oh I've been having this
debate with people in the Republican
party you think DeSantis is the favorite
oh we got a disagreement so you think in
the Republicans the Republican primary
the Republicans if we're talking Vegas
odds Vegas put the Santos at the top
then it's Biden then it's Trump no no
I'm saying in the Republican primary
Trump I think it's the Trump salute you
think it's a solution I totally disagree
now okay I think DeSantis is the
favorite right now Trump has I hope
you're right Kyle I think a lot of
people might what I said to you I'm
giving you Vegas odds yeah I'm sorry
Trump is two the Santa's one three is
Biden Trump is two desantises one these
are the odds that I trust these are the
polls that I trust
I don't disagree I'm telling you not you
not Rasmussen Quinnipiac Vegas so let me
give you the here's the problem with
Trump electorally in the 2018 election
Republicans got hammered he was the face
of the party in the midterm you mean or
26th 2018 in the midterm yeah in the
2020 election Republicans got hammered
Trump was the top of the ticket Trump
hasn't won since 2016 is what you're
about to say that is exactly right and
the other thing is the candidates who
were most tied to him Doug mastriano
Carrie Lake all the ones that were the
most trumpy elections yes they got
hammered and meanwhile you look at a
republican like Kemp in Georgia who is
not an election denier he won and he won
comfortably okay Larry Hogan in uh
Maryland so um
we're talking about honestly I think he
lost his step I think he lost more than
one step Trump did I mean if you see him
over on Truth social now he can't shut
up about the 2020 election it's non-stop
they rigged it they stole it it's
grievance 24 7. he's not talking about
what he wants to do with the country
he's not going after the elites he is
the whiny Elite he said the other day
terminate the constitution on social
media and all this answers has to do is
sit back and chill and let Trump
self-destruct and by the way he's
plotted his way along brilliantly for a
right-wing primary because he did that
thing the other day where it was like a
Roundtable event with a bunch of vaccine
skeptical people the right wing base
loved that there was something else that
he did which I'm blanket on at the
moment but he's been plotting his way
around perfectly where he's not
pro-trump he's not anti-trump he's just
sort of trump agnostic and doing his own
thing and a lot of people are leaving
Trump and going to DeSantis I think he's
the favorite for the Republicans what I
think you're saying is the magic he had
in 2015 2016 is gone it's gone I don't
think anybody would disagree with you
believe me believe it or not there are
people I've had this debate with Crystal
I've had this debate with soccer and I
love both of them but they they've held
strong to this day like no he's still
the Don well that's for 25 of the
country and 40 of the Republican base
that's great that that might win your
primary
that's not going to win your general
election I'm sorry how do you lose to a
walking Corp it's like Joe Biden Joe
Biden is yes you're that toxic of a
candidate correct but but let me go back
let me go back to the point I was trying
to make to you so why did the scientists
all of a sudden get you know he went
from winning by 34 000 votes in 2018
barely winning by 34 000 votes to now
1.5 1.6 million votes what did he do
to become the best governor in all of
America plus minus votes that's a form
of trust including Miami-Dade County
what did he do to become the number one
governor in America well I would say
first and foremost name recognition is
huge he's now the second biggest
Republican name in the country behind
Donald Trump so I think that's a big
thing but how do you get that name
because I honestly I think the media is
not nearly as anti-desantis as they were
anti-trump and he sort of gets part of
it credit though if he's no I will I but
I disagree with him so I'm not I'm not
trying to hide from it or whatever but I
understand that he did things that some
people like I don't like the things that
he did for example he's against raising
the minimum wage even though 60 of
Florida voters said they want to raise
the minimum wage he's against legalizing
marijuana he said it smells putrid so it
probably shouldn't be legalized these
are things I just disagree with now
where I will agree with you there's
politics and there's policy on policy I
don't agree with him at all on politics
I think he's a very good politician and
he's dangerous and he could get elected
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks right if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks proud
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]